everybody's gonna play here we are be
oratio
the west coast Tuscan coast and we're
here at carnival carnival sorry all of
Italy is celebrating Kearney of all
these a couple weeks and this is an
amazing experience there's tons of huge
floats here so we're gonna shoot a bunch
of stuff with Conan and Jordan getting
out out mystic peak
[Music]
right this is the one time of
I wanted to take you
folks there's clowns there's all kinds
of action
[Music]
we're riding away
[Music]
this is Mardi Gras
I wanted to get you out of here
this rigid box which is this is the town
of any this is the chef I know him I
know this later this is the table I see
that guess what
that's over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
American comedians
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yep
you see
[Applause]
[Applause]
Wow
[Applause]
whoo
to
[Music]
okay
the side where the blue stars
[Music]
yes I am
Oh
RAAA
[Music]
question
so how the Facebook hey Facebook how's
it going so what happened was we're in
this crazy parade as coastal town there
Vieira Vieira she is your gob ratio
coastal time of year Reggio walking on
the braid and then there's a cute host
stands filled with south korean hahaha
course I'm uh you know I've made my mark
and stuff Korea so they go crazy and
then on the Italian to see these people
going crazy and then the Italian
paparazzi starts to swarm me they don't
know who I am I don't think mr. [ __ ]
Pat Sajak
fortune so I think the story is going to
be that Patsy's active with him
the Reggio made an appearance but he's
much taller than you think also much
younger waiting your first carnival
fantastic
my first Italian first Italian Carla
many carnival cruises you don't seem to
be that happy about this Jordan is not
happy he did not want to come here I
wanted to be in control of the entire
trip - only in his restaurants is doing
here but I took control to this kooky
festival yeah it's like because he's
getting confetti
I made him dance to Ghana style which
seems to be just hitting the charts here
my horrifying romantic in there bill
yeah but like I said I moved in line to
see what you want to show me order
together physically leave the city soup
has no style everyone's taking my
picture again hi Pat Sajak that's a jack
yes of course yes and look it's an
Italian my god you [ __ ] for a funeral
everyone
you